salt interdit formellement de tous
horizons
[Musique]
c'est réalisons permettent d'accueillir
une structure de direction d' assurer
simultanément trois stages de formation
de 25 stagiaires des bergers 25
stagiaires et à nourrir 80 d'entre eux
des deux unités dans les domaines de
contre terrorisme en milieu urbain et
rural du tir et de la protection
rapprochée
comment
nous savons que notre responsabilité est
de combattre ensemble cet ennemi commun
dont les exactions au sahel nous
concerne directement
car sur la carte des menaces le sel et
la frontière sud de l'europe et la
frontière nord des états du golfe de
guinée
[Musique]